what's it gonna make us watch again this
time full of it
just reveal pretty big deal
satisfied
I think he's a good guy but yeah I
thought he was good I'm so happy that he
is because my feels like he hasn't
attacked anyone he's just been into it
maybe he's not the same class saying
that was no she can get killed by fire
she looks it thank you through dinner I
don't know something that he gave us
don't know what it is
she didn't even look at it now that
she's floated it's not gonna let me look
in it so I think Emily has a very good
chance of dying in the sink I feel like
she could have been put up there if I
love with the thing on fire I feel like
she could've died there but I think in
here she's got a good chance he died
Emily and we know that fires know he
went to pick up the desk tote with the
fire or is it just her in the picture we
do need to remember that she didn't pick
it up Chris picked it up it was tearing
a picture her in the picture
maybe I wonder if if that's when you
throw a guy we now know some reason he
has movies read this stuff maybe spill
it maybe he's not but for some reason he
have be as Beth's head but he's also a
good guy didn't hurt her he's just
trying to all the things that are in it
is there or is it another person they
could be yeah it could be unknown
another person so we have video and they
clearly written off
we've got victim who we think that guy
this is the awesome one and then we've
got another guy why do you keep going
down Emily yeah I really think there's a
good chance of her dying in this segment
Buster's we do need to get her out the
faster can you make loving the adoption
I might run across something she's
currently going it's pretty freaky in
here
as bad things in the Alice's toilet oh
no run button I always do that a keeper
thing I want it so hot - it's white
that's my gonna shoot some I'm not
shooting doesn't hear you do it again
I'm sure it was my going to shoot
someone and not cheating them good so it
doesn't kill Josh yeah good
sorry so we know now from sure that the
totems they pick up aren't necessarily
related to the characters unless she's
going to shoot Emily but I can't imagine
why
Mike would want to show Emily also do
they did date once but I don't have an
issue yeah yeah but I think that's
enough Mike to suddenly want to kill him
what the I like you know it's not gonna
turn to be Lovejoy other stage so how
does anyone ever love her oh really
she's a bit of a [ __ ] you think yeah
it's something that was a change
Eugenie's oh we've been here we've seen
this [ __ ] does not stop
[ __ ] up contrast matrix right I can't
do anything
I'm really worried about the cuties in
hey killing her if I get the moment you
know buttons I'm really worried about
killing my yeah
/ - if I get anything wrong original
diamond city whatever thing I don't know
if good do you think there is so I'm
still old gone wrong because they still
have handsome twin babies it could be a
song people that were totally messed up
and when it shut down that was sort of
just there she would not finish it
it doesn't seem safe alright alright Oh
oh my god oh my god oh my god I please
stop God holy [ __ ] she's oh my god she
was definitely going to die I can't
believe oh my god she totally would have
died that sure
this cost attracts tons of hate yes
we're thinking that they could either be
things that we've tortured in that we
had a salient it's why they got weirded
out yes or that they discovered them in
the mines and that's why there was the
thing we found that they wanted to
dynamite the mines and that's why they
wanted to leave possibly yeah how do you
bet that so it could be anything
and I'm thinking now Victor is good
Victor tried to save hundreds both from
this fighting awful thing if he is
Victor well that's what we're calling it
because it's awesome thing doesn't
matter who he actually is but then
there's if it wants to be called victim
we don't know if he's the same person
who was there when Jess died or is he we
don't know if he's the my - no I think
he's not I don't think he walks the same
way forgot the other guy walked with the
stupas into my home is viewed and all
the victim walk like a normal person
if its victim whatever I think they're
two separate people let's just say we're
calling in video 1 we have Victor the
once presume what yeah I think plants
are amazing good guy
ok so then the guy - chasing is a
different guy I think so yeah I reckon
there's more than one I definitely do
because they walk differently and I
think that address different yes true
but any wonder why one who died why does
he have oxygen pecs on his back is that
because he's a flamethrower does he have
any knee no no I think that's not oxygen
good one it's nice - in the ice fire
just yellow be food oil in the oil also
quicker yes yeah
okay so there was she was leaning
against a pole so right now there's
probably to be an obituary
I'm very you Lillis I'm very worried
about her dying right now absolutely
let's get her out of here
okay get off the [ __ ] wall give us
new details but oh [ __ ] another thing
don't know what
oh my god no she's not dead she's not
that she's not that to stuff she's not
dead but do they sing this [ __ ] thing
well they they hum that up I think that
that wants to stay birth to tell they
hung that up I think that wants to show
they're pretty smart I don't think the I
think they're just evil given killer
skin him we didn't kill us I ditched her
safe but she's not dead
she looks like
say yeah it is
there's a garment yeah
Julie yeah she's the watch she made it
back
oh did she what now she's something
because they might know about the The
Munsters
yeah - yeah actually shut the [ __ ]
door possible okay I think I was okay no
computers right yeah monster no no no
which one what happens yeah no confused
there's a million oh no you haven't this
mines everywhere
you tell about that time but maybe the
monsters were the ones who go bets head
is not the point terabyte do you admit I
think the monsters a dump do remember
when bits and the doll the people that
were tracking her working on sensors it
was red
yeah do you know they were being chased
by that that's why I'll answer about
earlier and though and those people that
were tracking in group doing this wrong
yes so if they loved yes
these messed up whatever's sorry I wanna
listen oh I'm sorry
it's not just